here's Trump's video that he put out
it's very stupid they go after a popular
president a president that got more
votes than any sitting president in the
history of our country irrelevant to
whether one committed a crime of course
by far
ended much better the second time in the
election than
the first irrelevant and they go after
him on a Box's hugs just like the Russia
Russia Russia hoax and all of the others
this has been going on for seven years
they can't stop because it's election
interference at the highest level
there's never been anything like what's
happened I'm an innocent man I'm an
innocent person they had the Mueller
hoax the Mueller report and that came
out no collusion after two and a half
years all right so it's basically the
typical grievances from Trump